Slatkin: Just--Hey, okay.
Hi. First session today,
so let's get into it.
This is "Offline Processing
on App Engine: A Look Ahead."
I'm Brett Slatkin.
I'm a software engineer
on the Google App Engine team.
And I'm really excited
to be able to talk to you
about some
really cool features
that we've been working on
for a while
that we're going to tell you
all about today.
Oh, yeah, and really quick,
some people thought
offline processing
was talking about mobile phones
and offline--
different kind of offline.
This is offline processing--
doing work offline,
as opposed to using
your mobile phone
when you don't have
connectivity.
So if you're in
the wrong session,
you won't hurt my feelings
if you leave.
All right,
so here's our agenda.
We're gonna talk about
a new API:
the Task Queue API.
We're gonna talk about
what tasks are.
web hooks.
We're gonna talk about
push versus pull,
and the performance
of those models.
We're gonna talk about
idempotence, queues,
and throttling.
Task names and ETAs.
And then we're gonna have some
example applications
using the Task Queue
interspersed
through the presentation,
including sending email,
Schema migration,
and write-behind cache.
And then finally we're gonna
talk about the future
of offline processing
on App Engine,
and what we have planned--
what's coming.
So I have a Moderator page
set up.
It's tinyurl.com/offlinetalk.
And you can give immediate
feedback about this presentation
on haveasec.com/io.
So please start putting
your questions in there.
All right, so let's just start
from the beginning.
Let's talk about
the motivation
of what we're trying
to accomplish here.
So hopefully, as you know,
if you've tried it out,
Google App Engine
is great for web apps.
We're very good for
request-based,
database-backed applications.
But that's a lot
of online processing.
You have to do things
within the boundaries
of a single request.
There's a limit to what
you can do during that time.
There are a lot of applications
that fit that model,
but there are a lot
that don't.
And that's why background
and batch processing are
two highly requested features
that people have been asking for
over and over again.
We've delivered that in part
with cron.
And cron's very useful
for doing work periodically
every so often.
But it's really not good enough
if you want to do a lot of work
or if you want to do work at a
very high frequency, high rate.
And if we actually delivered
background and batch processing,
it would enable a whole range
of new applications
on App Engine.
So, you know,
some people think that
not having offline processing
is a deal breaker,
and we're hoping
to remedy that.
So again, for background--
Why do you want to do
background processing?
Well, I want to do work
continuously
without user requests.
I don't want to have to be bound
to a single user request
in order
to get something done.
I want to incrementally
process data.
I want to compute some results,
aggregations,
whatever, what have you.
I also want to
smooth out load patterns
and reduce user latency.
So these are a few of them,
and we'll get into
what that actually means.
But what's really cool
about this is that
this is a new style of
computation on App Engine.
We're doing something
fundamentally different
than everything
we've done before.
Up until now, it's really about,
you know,
what can I do in a single
request from my user?
My talk yesterday,
and a lot of articles
you've seen
on our web site talk about
ways to optimize
for single requests,
ways to get a lot of work done
in a single request.
And we can finally
move past that
with some of the systems
we're building here.
So we're getting into
new territory,
and it's really exciting.
All right, so let's have
an introduction.
So we're going to talk about
our new API for App Engine.
We're calling it
the Task Queue API.
Now, the Task Queue API
is part of a new thing
we're calling App Engine Labs.
Labs is similar
to other Google Labs.
The word "labs."
So this means that
the API may change
until it's graduated
from Labs.
What does that mean?
So that means that
we're gonna try our best
to not make any backwards,
incompatible changes
to the API right now.
We're gonna try
to keep it stable,
but we're going to make
some small changes.
We're gonna maybe
move some things around,
make the API nicer in some ways.
We're gonna listen
to your feedback,
extend it,
take things away,
and make it
a really good API.
Once it's graduated
from Labs,
then we'll be dedicated
to having
a backwards-compatible API
for you to use
like the rest of our APIs,
where we don't break
your application
with subsequent releases
of our system
unless we specifically
send you an email telling you,
and have a full version change,
which we have not yet done.
So there'll be
a lot of warning
if we end up having
to change it.
Another part of App Engine Labs
is that we haven't specified
how we're gonna do billing yet.
We're still figuring out
the details of billing,
how this will be billed.
So we'll, you know,
look into that later
if you're wondering
about pricing,
and how that fits into
the rest of the billing system.
And hopefully this will be
the first of many APIs
that we're putting in Labs.
Now, Task Queue API
is not released today,
unfortunately--
I'm sorry to say that.
But it should launch
in a couple of weeks.
And I do--
it's not vaporware.
I have live--
I have the live version
of the Task Queue running
in our actual
production clusters.
And it's on App Spot,
so you'll be able to
actually see it in action and
take it for a spin for yourself.
And it has working code,
and so I'll be
sharing that with you.
Okay, so let's just do
some overview, some background,
since this is kind of
a new thing for a lot of people.
So what is a task queue?
Well, it's a simple idea,
in general.
You describe the work
that you want to do right now.
So, you know,
you have some idea--
I need to do something.
You describe it, and you save
that description
of the work somewhere,
very quickly.
And then later on, you come back
and you execute that work.
Three steps.
The work that you have saved--
the descriptions you've saved
are executed in the order
they were received.
So it's a best effort,
first in, first out queue.
So things that were added first
get done first.
Things added later
will get done later.
Okay, another important thing
is that
if execution fails
at this work,
it'll be retried
until it's successful.
So you have a very high level
of confidence
that something you put
in a queue will be completed.
Now, the smallest example
of a task queue API
would be something like this:
taskqueue.add,
some description of the work.
Whatever that means.
Do this later.
What is a task queue?
Why is it beneficial?
Why is it useful?
Well, first of all,
it's asynchronous.
Why do anything right now
if I could do it later?
I'm very lazy.
I don't want to have to wait.
So instead of, you know,
doing some very expensive,
very high-latency operation,
I'll just record the fact
that I have to do it
at some point in the future
and then just
deal with it later.
Because of that--
So that's one part.
The other part is that
it lets me do many operations
at the same time
asynchronously,
so that I don't have
dependencies
between my code of waiting
and stuff like that.
It's fundamentally
more event-driven.
This also results
in lower latency for our users,
so tasks are lightweight.
They're about three times faster
than our Datastore.
So if you want to save a task
to describe to do some work
in the future,
it's really fast.
Tasks are also reliable.
So what I was saying before--
once you write a task,
the guarantee is that
it will eventually complete,
depending on
what your code does.
But if you have working code,
it will eventually complete.
And tasks are scalable.
The storage of new tasks
has no contention.
You're just appending to the end
of a very large list.
So you can keep it pending
all the way to the end.
We can store those tasks
across a lot of machines.
So we can scale that out
very well.
And the best part is that
you can parallelize work
with multiple workers.
You can have a lot of workers
pulling off
the front of a queue
and completing work,
getting it done in parallel,
so you can do a lot
of computation simultaneously.
And there are a lot of features
you can add
to this basic concept.
So historically,
what is a task queue?
Well, UNIX had "at"
and "batch" commands.
Do this work, run this shell
command at this time.
And they had ways
of evaluating a queue,
adding things to a queue.
It's kind of an old style
of doing it.
What you hear about--
a lot of people
in the Django
and Rails community do
is they use a kind of
poor man's queue.
Some people have done this
on App Engine already.
You use cron jobs and flat files
to build a queue.
You append an entity
or a line to a queue
for every time you need
to do some more work.
And then every so often,
you wake up
and just consume the whole file
and the whole queue
with a cron job.
For a lot of people,
that's what a task queue is.
But there are a lot of
reliability
and scalability issues here.
You're locked into
a single machine
that contains a queue.
It's very hard
to parallelize work.
And there are
some failure scenarios
that you have to deal with.
It works, but it's really
not ideal.
But there are other
task queue systems out there
that are good,
and let's talk about
some of them.
So there's a long list.
It's a very, very long
laundry list.
Here I have *MQ.
*MQ is all the MQ systems
out there.
There's ActiveMQ from Apache.
There's RabbitMQ,
which is Erlang.
There's Microsoft MQ,
WebSphere MQ.
Basically any vendor MQ.
There's Amazon Simple Queue
Service,
Azure queues, from Microsoft.
There's TheSchwartz
open-source queuing service.
Twisted has some queue-like
asynchronous stuff in it.
Starling is an in-memory queue
that's getting kind of popular.
Beanstalkd is kind of
the same idea.
And there's a lot
of others.
But one thing I'd like
to point out here is that
task queues are often conflated
with pub-sub messaging.
People talk to us and they say,
"We want task queues."
Or no, "We want pub-sub,"
or "We want JMS."
Or, "I want a messaging system."
It's like, well,
what do you want?
What do you
actually want to do?
So let's define what we're
actually talking about here
so you can understand
the motivation of our API
and why it is the way it is.
So queuing systems
maximize data throughput.
That's what they're for.
Routers, data pipelines--
these are queuing systems.
They fully saturate a network,
CPU, disk.
They're meant for throughput.
That's the goal.
Pub-sub systems are about
transactions and decoupling.
Now, what do I mean
by "decoupling"?
I mean you can have
consumers and producers
on the same network,
maybe multiple consumers
for a single producer,
and the consumers and producers
don't need to know
anything about each other.
You can change the software
on either side.
They have some contract
between them
that lets them
be decoupled.
Businesses really like this
because it lets them be agile
and change vendors
and, you know,
get around lock
and all this other stuff.
Pub-sub is very useful
for that.
It's good at large numbers of
small transactions per second.
It's good for one-to-many
fan-out.
When you're changing
the receivers, you're adding
new business logic,
new business rules.
And a lot of the time,
pub-sub systems, MQ systems
have a lot of extra things
added to them.
They're got filtering.
They've got guaranteed ordering.
You can have two-phase commit
in there.
There's a whole slew of other
rules and transformations
that a lot
of these systems do.
And that's all very
interesting stuff.
There are some really good
use cases for it.
But our goal here is queuing,
not pub-sub.
We're looking
for high throughput,
maximizing data throughput.
So that's an important
distinction to keep in mind.
So here's how
a normal task-queuing system,
or MQ system, works.
You have a queue,
newer tasks going to the right.
You have some queue mediator
or a set of queue mediators.
They look
at the head of the queue.
They pop off that head.
And then you have
a series of workers
that are polling the queue
mediator for new tasks.
So worker A, B, and C constantly
are contacting the mediator
saying, "Hey, do you have
any work yet?"
And the queue mediator says no,
and then it goes
back and forth.
And the workers
are always running.
They're always polling.
They're sitting there
doing nothing most of the time,
depending on what
your queue is doing.
Now, polling has problems.
A lot of problems.
I--Yeah, I don't like polling
at all.
The worker sits in a loop
polling the front of the queue.
That means
it's not event-driven.
That's wasted work.
That's just a lot of,
hey, you know--
like a little child tugging
at somebody's shirt
or something like that.
It's just a waste of time
for the worker.
The workers stay resident
when there's no work to do,
and that just wastes
machine resources.
You have all these workers for
peak load that you don't need
just sitting there
doing nothing.
Another problem is that
it's a fixed number of workers.
You have this IT burden.
Admins have to manually add
more workers
to keep up with the queue
or the queue
grows without bounds.
So you need to sit there
and say, "Oh, man,
"at noon my queue gets
to 1 million items long.
"I really need to spool up
a few more workers
during that time."
Or you just leave
those workers on all the time.
So you've got this
management bird in your head
you have to think about
with polling
to make sure that you kind of
keep things under control.
And you have to yourself,
as an administrator,
be constantly readjusting
your worker pool
to properly handle
your task queue
to make sure it's
low latency.
And the other problem
with polling is that
there's a limited amount
of optimization possible.
So many systems
do fake a polling interface
with something that's
event-driven under the hood.
Essentially they use
long-live connections that say,
"Hey, give me something
whenever you're ready
and I'll just hang
on this connection."
And then the queue mediator
eventually gets a task,
and then sends it
down the wire.
So you can reduce
some of the latency
from when a task is enqueued
to when it's executed.
But you still have this
fundamental problem of workers.
Number of workers,
queue size, et cetera.
So how is our task queue
different?
We don't poll, we push.
We push tasks to your app.
There's no polling
necessary.
That's--That's big.
The second big thing is that
we are doing tasks
as web hooks.
So when you want
to execute a task,
we're using web hooks
as the interface.
Now, what are web hooks?
It's a RESTful,
push-based interface
for doing work.
It's a concept that's used
outside of Google,
outside of App Engine.
But we really like the style,
and a lot of our coming APIs
are gonna use this style.
You should go to this
Wikipedia page
if you want to know more.
Essentially, what you're doing
is describing an interface
through simple HTTP.
A set of URLs, post body, says
here's the input interface
and here's the output interface
that I expect.
So your standard communication
interface becomes HTTP.
That's all web hooks are.
A great example
of a web hook system is
Google Code has a post-commit
web hook,
so that anytime someone commits
to the SVN repository,
you can get an HTTP post
to your web server
so you can do all kinds
of clean up or send emails
or do announcement,
et cetera.
So it's a really easy way
to interface
server-to-server communication
to integrate systems together.
So web hooks are really great.
Now, in App Engine,
we're doing tasks as web hooks.
So a task--
When you define a task,
you're just defining
an HTTP request
you want to have executed.
You give us the URL,
the body of the HTTP request,
the method, headers,
query string parameters,
content type, et cetera.
You just define, hey,
I want this request later on
on this handler.
You enqueue that task,
and then we send your app
the request later.
And then the interface is,
if your web hook--
So we make that request with all
the parameters you wanted.
And then if your web hook
gives us back an HTTP 200 okay,
then it's done.
Anything else, we will say
that the task failed,
and we'll back off
and retry later.
So it's really simple.
The interface is whatever
you want it to be.
It's just HTTP.
So here's a really
simple example of this.
I've defined--
This is Python.
I've defined
a web request handler here.
It takes posts,
and it's using our mail API
to send an email.
So it's sending an email
from me@example.com.
It's pulling some
query string posts
for some form-encoded
parameters.
So I get the "to,"
a "subject," and the "body."
And I just send the mail.
That's it.
It's just a really simple--
You could have a form
that drives this,
very simply.
And then to enqueue a task,
I just say, oh, yeah,
here's where my handle is--
handler is.
Here are the parameters
that I want to encode.
And that's it. Add it.
So this calls this,
just sometime in the future.
Now, why would you want
to do it in this case?
Well, our mail API
is synchronous.
So when you send an email,
you're looking at, you know,
500 milliseconds, one second,
two seconds to send that email.
If a user's clicking
a button,
that could be
a bad experience for them.
So by doing it this way,
you're looking at, you know,
10, 20, 30 milliseconds
for getting the task enqueued,
and you're on your way.
It's a lot faster.
So, demo.
This is a funny demo because
I don't have Gmail loaded.
So I'll just show you
how fast it is.
I don't know if you've ever
used mail sending,
but I'm just gonna send
an email to myself.
So by the time that reloads,
I've sent an email to myself.
It's really fast.
That's me enqueuing a task
over and over again.
I'm not gonna bring up my email.
I have all kinds of
personal conversations
with my grandma.
So I'm sorry I didn't
clear those out before today.
But you get the idea,
it's quicker.
Um--
Oh, wrong slide.
All right...
So let's talk about
how our task queue works.
So it looks exactly the same,
except we've inverted
a lot of the relationships here.
We still have a task queue.
We still have
a queue mediator,
but the arrows go
in the other direction.
The queue mediator's
pulling off of head.
And then--
Whenever there's work.
And then it's sending it
to your request handler.
If there's no work to do--
you don't have any
request handlers active,
there are no active threads--
you're not wasting
any resources on workers
that aren't doing anything.
Conversely, if you have
more work to do,
we just spool up
more threads.
It's just the way
that App Engine works
handling HTTP requests.
We do the exact same thing
for tasks.
So if you have more work to do
in your queues,
we will spool up a lot
of threads to consume them.
And as soon as
that work is done,
we'll pull those threads
back in again.
And they don't cost anything
to have--
It doesn't cost anything
to have those threads resident.
So we're automatically adjusting
the worker threads
based on the load
to the needs
of your application
and the needs of your queue.
So you get to save
a lot of waste--
Just from that inversion
of the model--
from pull and pull to push.
So yeah, we add worker threads,
depending on the workload.
The maximum number of threads
depends on your throughput.
So if your tasks take,
you know, 30 seconds each,
you're gonna have a lower
overall throughput
of tasks per second.
But, yeah--but we have
a high maximum rate limit
for tasks per second processed.
So you can get
a lot of work done.
And another thing that's great
is that it's just integrated
into the admin console
as normal requests.
So all the things that
you already use with App Engine
to debug your requests
and look at your logs
and figure out
how things work,
they continue to work right now.
The application and request logs
are still searchable.
You can get all of your logs
from your request handlers.
You can see the web hook
response codes:
200 OK or 500s.
You can scan through
your logs,
do regex searches,
all that stuff.
The dashboard statistics
and error-rate monitoring
are still there.
So one of the things
that's really great
about our admin console is
we show per URL CPU usage
on average.
So using that exact same idea,
you can have a URL
that's your mail worker,
or a URL that's
your compute worker,
and you can see, oh,
each one of my tasks
is taking 200 milliseconds
of CPU time on average.
You can use that same scheme
of URLs and URL monitoring
to optimize your application.
CPU...sorry, what?
CPU cycle?
man: [indistinct]
Slatkin: Oh, 200 milliseconds
of CPU time.
So...well,
ask me that question later.
On App Engine, we define
resources in terms of CPU time.
So it's a standard CPU.
Yeah.
So...oh, yeah, the same thing
with error rates.
We monitor error rates.
So if you want to see
how many tasks in your queue
have an error,
you get to see that too.
So all the nice things
in the admin console,
including graphs,
they're all there.
So let's get into some details
and some more examples.
So first of all
I want to warn you
about something called
idempotence.
Idempotence is a mouthful
of a word.
If you're a programmer,
you've probably heard it before,
but it took me a while to
remember exactly what it meant.
Effectively, what idempotence is
is that, you know,
we need to be able to run
the same tasks repeatedly
without harmful effects.
Or at least effects
that are acceptable,
like sending a duplicate email.
Now, why is this
necessary?
It's necessary because
failure can happen at any time.
With our Task Queue API,
we're giving you a guarantee
that the task will be retried
until it's successful.
But it's on you to actually
implement the task handler.
So you need to keep in mind
that your tasks may run twice
on accident--
either because of your code,
or because of a failure
of one of our systems,
or even in good cases
without server failure,
it's still theoretically
possible
for a task to run twice.
So you need to be idempotent.
It's your responsibility
as the application developer
to ensure that your tasks
are idempotent
so that if you run
the same task twice,
you have a way to figure out
either I did this before,
or I can do this again,
and it's not harmful.
[inaudible question]
And they won't run in parallel.
That's a good question.
One task is only running
on one thread at one time,
but there are still
tiny little edge cases
where it could be two.
And we're getting into
some cookbook kind of stuff
to make sure that
that doesn't happen too.
But yeah,
you should be guaranteed
that you have tasks running--
Only one task should be running
in one place at a time.
But yeah,
it's the same concept.
Idempotent operations
require you to--
Require your application
to allow for repeats,
sometimes simultaneously.
[inaudible question]
Right, so the question is
could you use memcache
to say I already did this?
Or the Datastore--yeah, you
could do something like that.
There are some latency issues
with doing that,
but yeah, there's some--
You could use memcache locks.
You could use a few
other techniques
to make sure that you don't
do things multiple times.
But again, the burden is on you
as a developer.
We don't do this for you,
but we give you tools to do it.
Now let's talk about queues.
We talked about tasks.
We also have queues--
This is Task Queue API.
So each task is added
to a single queue for execution.
And we allow for multiple queues
in an application.
So what is a queue?
Well, a queue provides isolation
and separation of tasks.
So that means that, you know,
it's a FIFO queue.
Tasks enter at the back
and go to the front.
Maybe one queue is slower
than some other queues.
You want to have isolation
between them.
Maybe you want one queue
to run faster than another.
You can do all that
by configuring your queues.
A queue in our system
is really just a line.
It's a queue--a list of items
that have to progress
in that order.
And so if you care about
the ordering
across multiple tasks
with different priorities,
or something like that,
you can use different queues
to control that.
And you do it
with a queue.yaml file.
So here's an example.
I have two queues--
a mail_queue, which I only want
to have work 2,000 times a day,
and I have a speedy_queue,
which I want running
at a maximum consume rate
of five per second.
So this is fundamentally
different than
your normal task-queuing system.
With a lot of task-queuing
systems,
you split up new workers
when you think you need
to do more work.
On our side we're, like, hey,
we're gonna run a lot
of tasks per second.
You need to tell us
a reasonable maximum
so that we don't
overload things.
And in the future
we've thought about
also putting a maximum number
of tasks in flight
simultaneously per queue
or a maximum burn rate
of CPU per queue--
something you could specify
in this file.
There's a lot of things
we could add here.
We're still figuring out
what you guys want.
But why would you actually
want to throttle?
Well, you may want
to combine work periodically,
execute the work in batches.
You may want to ensure
the stability of your workload.
Make sure that your CPU
and bandwidth
and dollar spend
is consistent.
You can use queue throttling
to make sure that
you don't exceed the maximum
writes per second
of a single entity group
in the Datastore.
Make sure that you don't
overload a partner site
with web service calls,
send two emails at a time,
or hit your email quota.
And it also just enables
the prioritization of work.
So remember that tasks
are defined as a web hook.
Tasks go to any URL.
So you have as many receivers
as you want as you have URLS.
So the routing of the tasks
is totally independent
of the queues.
The queues are just a way
of throttling your tasks.
So think of queues as a way
to do flow control of your tasks
that's independent of what
the tasks actually do.
And to illustrate that
I have this many-to-many
queue throttling diagram.
So on the left side I have
the mail tasks--
mail tasks, fetch tasks,
and compute tasks.
They're totally different tasks.
They go to different handlers.
Completely separate
from everything else.
On the right side I have
a bunch of workers
that handle each of those
corresponding tasks.
Now, I have three queues
at a different rate.
Each providing, say,
a different level of service,
a different CPU burn
depending on how important
I think something is.
If I have a customer that
I think is really important,
I want their email
to go out first.
Other free customers,
I put them in the queue
with the rest of the people
who have
low-priority emails to send.
So the queue, again,
is not bound to the task.
They're independent.
The queue is a way
of keeping track
and controlling
your task's progress.
So keep that in mind.
All right, so let's do
some more concrete examples.
The first one is Schema--
So we did the first one,
which was sending mail.
Another one is Schema migration.
People have said, "How do I do a
Schema migration on App Engine?"
We finally have
a decent answer for you.
So before, you could use
a cron job
to slowly iterate
through your entities,
migrate them, and then store
your entity location
in memcache.
The problem with this
is that it was slow.
You'd have to periodically wake
up, do a little bit of work,
and then go back to sleep,
over and over.
You couldn't parallelize
any of the work.
Just generally it was slow.
It wasn't event driven.
You had to do a lot
of waiting.
Another option was to use
a remote_api or the bulkloader
to dump the whole dataset
and re-upload it.
That's slow--it uses a lot
of bandwidth, a lot of CPU.
A lot of the time your
transformations are very tiny.
Sometimes you can edit
your entities in place.
You don't even have
to rewrite them.
So there's just a lot of cost
associated
with dumping
your entire Datastore.
Now, with the task API,
it gets a lot easier.
You define a handler to query
for the next "N" entities.
You modify them,
update them in batch,
and then enqueue a task
to resume
after the current position.
And a failure at any point
will cause a task
to be retried later,
picking up exactly
where you left off.
So let's look at some code
to do this.
So first of all I have--
Here's my really simple Schema.
I have two model classes:
a FirstUserKind,
a SecondUserKind.
Initially I just had a name.
Later I realized I want to
be able to sort my last names,
so I have the SecondUserKind,
with the first
and last name separated.
Then I have two migration
functions.
I have--give me
a SecondUserKind from the first,
and vice versa.
So you'll see that to get
a SecondUserKind,
I just split on the space,
and that gets me
the first and last name.
And for the other way around,
I just combined them together.
So here's a migration function.
This is inside
a web request handler
just like any other
web request handler
that would be receiving
the web hook call for the task.
So I query--
So here there's a few
hidden variables.
I'll explain what they mean.
So the from_kind is
the model class
that I'm migrating from.
So that'll be either
first or second kind.
And then--so I will start
a query on those.
If I have a position--
Like, if I'm iterating
through the list,
I have a start position
I'm keeping track of,
so I'm doing a key query
to page through all my data
as I do my migration.
So that's what this "if" is.
So then I grab ten
of the old entities.
If there are
no old entities done--
If there are no
old entities left, I'm done.
Otherwise, I figure out,
you know,
here are my old entities--
I get the next one.
So this is where I'll start
for the next batch.
And then I migrate
all my entities
to create the new list.
So migrate "X" for "X" in old.
Then I put the new entities,
and I delete the old entities.
And then I enqueue
another task
to do the exact same
web request handler again,
with the start
equal to my next position
and then the kind being
the same migration path.
So the same migration kind--
the "from" kind.
Now, what's really interesting
about this example
is it illustrates the important
order of operations
for idempotence.
So for instance, you'll notice
that I first migra--
So first I query
for all the old ones,
and then I put the new ones
in the Datastore.
So if the query failed, I'll
start in exactly the same place.
If putting the new ones
in the Datastore--
Sorry, if the order
were reversed,
and I deleted the old ones
before putting the new ones,
I could lose data.
So I want to migrate--
write the new ones,
have a duplicate data
before I delete the old ones...
so that we can have
failures there.
Another thing that's
not clear from this
is that in the migration
function,
I need to make sure that
I can put the same entity twice.
So if I migrate
from Schema One to Schema B--
Schema A to Schema B--
I can overwrite Schema B
if the task reruns
over and over again.
And that's idempotence--
to make sure that
if there's a failure
during that put,
that I don't have
duplicate data.
And then finally,
if the delete fails
halfway through, that's fine.
I've already done a put,
and my query won't
give me anything,
so I'll just move on.
So I can give you
a demo of this.
So again, this is running
on App Spot.
So here's Schema migrations.
So I have a series of names:
Hungry Time, Fluffy Cat,
Upside Down, Thunder Sandwich--
a bunch of weird ones.
These are some names
of people I know.
And I have a little script
to add names,
and I can migrate
from the first entity kind
to the second entity kind.
So I'll just click the button,
it'll start migrating,
and it's done.
Now, you'll notice that
it returned a partial migration
before the request was
even done.
So let me go back
the other way
to show you what
I'm talking about--
how fast it is.
Now let's go second to first.
I click the button,
and it's already--
three of them are
already done.
And by the time I reload again,
now they're all done.
So if you actually
go into--
Here I have my request logs
to show you this in action.
You'll see--
You see, here's
my start migration request.
And it's at 56 seconds.
This is hard to read, but I'll
just explain it to you.
So this served a 302 result
at 56.83 seconds.
By 56.87 seconds--
40 milliseconds later--
my migration task was
already in flight.
And then after that,
at 56.95, right here,
I've finally refreshed the page.
That means that
we're dispatching the tasks
to your workers
before the browser completes
a round-trip.
That's how fast
we're doing this.
When you add a task,
it can actually be reentrant,
so that the task is executing
before the API call comes back.
So it's very fast.
All right, so we have
two more little things to cover,
and then we'll have
one more example,
and then we'll get
to some questions.
Let's keep going here.
Another nice thing we have,
which is an advanced feature
of Tasks, is we have an ETA.
This is more of like the "at"
and "batch" UNIX commands.
It's an estimated time
of arrival.
It says how long until
the task should be executed.
So I can add a task now and say,
hey, in five minutes
I want to do this,
in one hour I want to do this,
in a day I want to do this.
This is very different
than a visibility time-out.
Visibility time-outs
are something you hear about
in Azure Queues
and Simple Queue Service
and a few others.
Visibility time-outs
are more about eliminating
possibly overlapping workers.
This is unrelated to those.
So this is just useful
for defining work to do
in the relatively near future.
It's more fine-grained
and gives you more
programmatic control than cron.
And it has a bunch
of useful things you can do.
You can periodically clear
a cache, flush a buffer,
report some incremental results,
prioritize some tasks
based on a schedule
with a short time window
or based on a schedule of some
algorithm you've developed.
I can think of a bunch of 'em,
but you know,
if you know that, oh,
five minutes from now,
I need to wake up
and do something,
that's what an ETA is good for,
without having to have
another cron job sitting there
polling for new work to do.
So again, ETAs are supposed
to eliminate polling.
Another thing that we provide
are names.
So each task has a unique name
given by the app.
If you don't give us
an app--
If the app doesn't
give us a name,
then we will auto-generate
an ID for you.
But what's interesting is that
if you give us this name,
we'll do something cool
with it.
So when the task is done,
we'll actually tombstone
that task for a few days.
We'd like to make that
configurable, eventually.
But what this does is,
if you add another task
with the same name,
you'll get an error.
So this lets you enforce
"only-once" semantics.
So why is that useful?
Well, I showed you
my Schema migrate button.
My dataset's kind of trivial.
It doesn't matter.
What if I click that button
twice in a row really fast?
What would happen?
I'd have a bunch of workers
working in parallel
trying to hurt each other,
potentially breaking my system.
So with only-once semantics,
I can make it so that
the first task I insert
to kick off the process
will only ever be inserted once.
And if it's inserted again,
you'll get an error.
So I can be guaranteed that
the beginning of this flow
or some part of task flow
will only happen once.
So, you know, migrate the Schema
for these entities once,
and only once.
Okay, so now let's have
another concrete example
of some of the things
you can do.
I'm trying to just give you
a taste for these--
these various options.
So this one's...
it's a little more complicated.
So the other ones were
kind of about offline work,
talking about Schema migration
or latency elimination.
This one's load elimination.
This is a way of making your app
more efficient,
more cost-effective
using the Task Queue.
So what is a write-behind cache?
So a write-behind cache
minimizes writes
by repeatedly flushing
a cache.
So essentially, what you do is
you write new data--
modified data--to the cache,
and only to the cache.
Like an in-memory cache.
And then you periodically
read that cache
and persist it to disk.
Now, why would you want
to do this?
Well, the benefit is that
database writes are no longer--
they no longer increase
as a function of user traffic.
So you can actually put your
database writes on a schedule.
Say, hey, I don't want to do
a database write
more than once per second.
So then you can turn
100 cache writes per second
into one database write
per second.
You've somehow suddenly
decoupled your traffic
from your database
load patterns.
So that gives you a huge amount
of scalability
that you couldn't do before.
Now, there's a problem.
There's a small time window
where you can lose the data
that was in the cache.
But if you think about it,
there's always
a small time window
where you can lose this data.
The data can be lost
over the wire
at any point in time.
The response can
not get back to the client.
Even a Datastore transaction
can fail halfway through.
It would roll back
in that case.
But, you know,
you are always dealing
with small failure windows.
So I think it plays well
into those same failure windows.
Now, I have a diagram
to show you how this works.
This is a sequence diagram--
a UML-style sequence diagram.
If you're not familiar
with this,
time goes both down and right,
kind of.
But yeah, time is going towards
the bottom of the screen.
So the user is using
a web application.
And they do some
data modification.
That goes to a request handler,
which writes into the cache,
which is a very fast
operation.
Then they add a task, which is
also a very fast operation.
And remember again,
the cache is super-fast
for writes and reads.
And adding tasks
has no contention--
also very fast.
So it scales very well.
Then we return a response
to the user
either using the cache
as the Datastore--
the cache
as the source of record--
or just telling the user
to wait a little while.
Now, sometime in the future,
the Task Queue
will dispatch that task.
The tasks will go
to a request handler.
I'm kind of not
showing that here
because it's kind of confusing.
But the task, as it executes,
will do a periodic read
from the cache,
and then it will go and write
in batch to the Datastore
the data from the cache.
So you see that we have--
we write to cache at the top.
That's step one.
That's all the stuff up here.
And then down here is
where we actually
purge the cache,
or flush the cache to disk.
Now, the problem that
can happen here
is the cache can fail
in this window.
If you saw what
I showed you before,
tasks are dispatched
in a reentrant manner.
They happen really fast.
So that window
can be very small.
And the window is also
configurable by your code.
You can set how often
you want to purge the cache--
or write the cache out.
So it's up to you
to figure out
what your tolerance
for error is,
and what you're willing
to accept
in terms of failures.
But our cache is very stable.
Memcache is very reliable.
And most of the time--
the vast majority of the time--
this is a huge win,
and this cache failure
is not a big problem.
Oh, and also mention that
there are a lot of things
you can do
on the client side
to deal with cache failures
like this.
So the client can do
an operation,
and then verify
that it actually worked,
you know,
10, 20 seconds later.
So let's go to the really
concrete example
of how to use
write-behind cache.
So many people have asked for,
a bunch of times,
our page-hit counters,
or just counters in general.
So without the Task Queue API,
you had to use something
like sharded counters,
which are relatively expensive,
problematic,
use a lot of storage space,
still have time-outs.
They were a good Band-Aid,
but they really don't give you
any control over
write throughput.
You're still doing
a Datastore write
on every single increment.
With Task Queue,
we use a write-behind cache.
Every time a hit comes in,
you just increment a counter
in memcache,
and then enqueue a task.
Then, with your task, you just
copy the value from memcache
and then write it
to Datastore.
And you use the queue
throttle rates
that we talked about before
to limit the max writes
per second
you want in your Datastore.
So some of you, if you've
put our Datastore to the test,
you know that if you exceed some
amount of writes per second
for a single entity group
or a single entity,
you'll start to get
some time-outs or contention.
This is a way
of eliminating that.
You just say, hey, I know that,
experimentally,
I've verified
that this is the fastest
I can write this entity.
I will just throttle my queue
to that many per second,
and that's that.
And then on the client's side,
from the request handler's side,
you can read from memcache
or the Datastore.
Both are sufficient sources
of record
because the window between
when the cache is updated
and the Datastore is updated
is very small.
Or it's as small
as you want it to be.
So let's look at some code.
I have a counter.
Here it's an IntegerProperty.
I have "indexed" set to false,
just because I want it
to be fast.
That's a new feature we have.
It lets you have
an unindexed property.
My CounterHandler,
this is where, actually--
This is the user code
that increments the counter.
So I pull the key
out of the requests.
I go to memcache and I try
to increment the key.
If the key was not already
in memcache,
I'll get back "none."
So then I'll try to add the key
to memcache with the number "1."
If my add was not successful,
that will also fail,
which means that somebody else
added that number
at the same time I did,
which means that I can
actually increment again.
This is kind of a funny
kind of, like,
two-step lock scheme
with memcache
to make sure that
you never drop a count.
But effectively,
these three lines of code here,
they just ensure that
I'm incrementing by one.
And then once I've done that,
I add a dirty flag,
which basically just says
in memcache
that this counter needs
to be written to Datastore.
And what's key here is
I'm using memcache.add.
memcache.add only adds
if it hasn't been added before.
And if it's already
been added,
then I get back "false."
And so what that means is that
I only add a task to the queue
when I know there's not already
a task in the queue.
Okay?
So if there's a task in flight
or a task that's gonna run,
I don't do anything.
I just sit there
because I know, eventually,
the flush is gonna happen.
But if the task
isn't going to run,
then I enqueue the task.
So then on the worker side,
I just have another--
It's another web request
handler.
You'll see I have
my task defined.
I have a worker URL and the key
of the thing to flush.
And I go in and I say--
First I delete
the memcache key.
And that immediately will
get rid of that block
so that new tasks
can be added to the queue.
And that's to get rid
of the window
of any race conditions.
So that's kind of
a funny lock
around the task
that's been enqueued.
Then I go and I get the value
out of memcache--
the current counter value.
If it's none, then I know
that I have a cache failure.
And that's the error condition:
I failed.
And that should hopefully be
a small window,
but it's possible.
So I'd have, maybe, some better
error-handling code in there.
And then I just create
a counter with a named key,
I set the value,
and I put it in the Datastore.
That's it.
Now, if this task fails
at any moment,
it should be able
to pick up again.
The memcache delete
will just do nothing
because I'm running
the task again.
If there were another task
that are executed again
on top of this one,
they basically just
do the same thing--
that's fine.
The queue will
throttle them properly,
so I don't have to worry about
exceeding my number
of entity group writes
per second.
And then the counter-put
will put over the top
of whatever value's there.
So I have a very safe way
of updating a counter
and controlling the rate
of writes.
So demo...
So I already have
a few here.
People have been messing around.
That's cool.
Add "foo" so I can
increment the count.
Let's see if that's working.
I might have broken my code.
Yeah, it looks like
I broke my code.
Well, it works.
Now, you're saying--
Well, you're probably saying
to yourself,
"I could write that.
"I have something that looks
just like that.
"You add a count,
and it shows up in a list.
"Why are you using task queues
to do that?
That's so silly."
But earlier when I was doing
this demo...
Yeah, is it working now?
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, so it is increasing.
I guess it just doesn't like
"foo."
That's cool. Cool.
All right, it's working.
Yeah, so I say "meep,"
I click "increment."
By the time it's reloaded,
meep's at seven...right?
I probably got some errors
in there.
So what happens is,
if a task fails,
we back off for a little while
and then try again.
The code's a little buggy, so
that's probably what's going on.
But let's look at my log.
I have a counter here,
and I've done--
So here's a counter
with a 302.
This is my post.
That's when I said "increment."
Then you see--so you see
there's a post right here.
Then the write-behind
comes through.
That's the task running.
So the first one comes at--
Okay, so I say increment
this counter at 18.1 seconds...
18.10.
The task is already running
by 18.19.
And then my browser does
a round-trip
and finally re-polls the data
at 18.42.
So from the user's perspective,
it's if the page did
the operation itself.
But it didn't work that way.
It's all done
in the background,
but it just happens
really quickly.
Okay, so those are
the practical things you can do.
I'm just gonna talk
about the future real quick,
and then we'll get
into some questions.
So Task Queue is coming soon.
We're gonna release
the Task Queue API
in App Engine Labs.
It's Python-only at first,
but Java is coming soon after.
The Java support in the works
will support
both the web hooks interface
and, we plan, JMS integration.
Now, like I said before,
this is not pub-sub,
but there are
some very good mappings
between queuing systems
and pub-subs.
So we're looking to have
some level of JMS compatibility
so that you can use JMS systems
with our Task Queue API.
We're also working on a lot more
Task Queue API features
in the coming months.
A lot of management functions,
like flushing a queue.
We want to have the ability
to view the contents of queues
in the admin console.
And we want you
to be able to get
other web hook notification
events
when a queue has finished
all of its processing,
or any kind of meta events
with the queue.
But let's talk more
about the future
of just offline processing
and App Engine in general.
So with batch processing,
the Task Queue API is good
for small datasets--you know,
100,000 rows or less.
But we really need some
more tools for parallelization
and high throughput processing
of Datastore entities.
We need a really efficient way
of splitting all of your data
into pieces so that you can
chunk through it in parallel.
Right now we don't have
enough tools for that.
So we're working on those.
We also need some
better features
for doing aggregations and
statistics kind of calculations
with your entities.
So we'll hopefully
get to those soon.
We also want to support
MapReduce.
Full-on MapReduce--
a MapReduce abstraction.
I don't know where this fits
on our timeline.
We're gonna talk more about it
as time goes on.
But before we get there,
we need some more tools.
We need more efficient
intermediary storage.
The Datastore is quick,
but it's not fast enough.
We need something very fast
if we want to use a lot of data.
We need something that's better
for shorting and shuffling.
We've got a lot of work
to do.
And especially because we want
our MapReduce abstraction
to work with both small datasets
and very large datasets--
over a terabyte or bigger.
So to wrap up...
use the Task Queue API,
once it's launched.
Make your existing app faster,
lower latency.
Scale your app further
with lower costs.
Add new functionality
you couldn't implement before.
The sky's the limit.
You know, you can implement
an event web site
for you and your friends.
You could make
a feed aggregator.
There's all kinds of stuff
you can do now
that you could never do before.
And take advantage of web hooks
for easy debugging.
Web hooks let you use a forum
to test your workers.
It's ridiculously easy.
So let's get to questions.
I think we have
ten minutes left.
There are mics here and here.
We also have them
on Moderator.
And if you have more feedback,
you can go to haveasec.com/io.
[applause]
Okay, so I'm just gonna
go through
the first three Moderator,
and then I'll do
the other questions.
So if you guys want
to talk to each other,
please go outside the room
so we can all talk together here
about this talk still.
We'll also be at office hours
for anyone who has questions.
So come on by.
I will be there all day.
Okay, so are tasks limited
by the 30-second time limit?
Yes, they are.
They are.
So we let you segment tasks
into multiple tasks.
We let tasks add new tasks
when they're done.
It's pretty easy
to segment your data.
We'd like them to be able
to run longer.
We're looking into it.
But yes, for now they are
also limited to 30 seconds.
Can we limit the number
of retries
and have a method
to process failed tasks
with, say, a failback
or resolution handler?
I think you can do a lot of this
in user space right now
by having some auxiliary data.
But yeah, this is one
of those features
that we could totally add on top
of the existing abstraction.
So it's something
we'll definitely consider
with all the other features
we'd like to add.
Will the APIs provide
the ability
to query the queue,
see how deep,
the processing rates,
intercept tasks
that have retried
a bunch of times?
So yeah, we'd like to provide
APIs for all this stuff.
We're starting with
the admin console
to give you a lot
of good diagnostics
into how your queues are going,
how old the tasks are,
flow rates, error rates,
et cetera.
A lot of this centers around
what the admin console needs
to give you a great picture
of what your queues are doing.
And we'd also like to provide
those APIs to our users.
Okay, I'll get to this one
in a minute.
So let's start with just
questions in person. Yeah?
man: Yeah, going back to your
migration example,
you mentioned
how important it is
to put the migrated entity
before deleting the old one.
I wonder whether you use
key names to identify--
Slatkin: That's exactly
what you use.
Yeah, you use key names
or the ID to identify the data.
So yeah.
man: Can you put the new entity
with the same key name
as the old one
before deleting it?
Slatkin: Yes, if the kinds are
different, you can.
So IDs and key names are
specific to an entity kind,
like a model class.
So you can use the same ID
for both,
and they won't affect
each other
because the primary key
is actually used as the kind.
So yeah,
that's how you do it.
man: So the migrated entity
will have to be a new kind?
Slatkin: It would be--exactly.
It would be a new kind.
If you didn't want to do
a new kind,
you'd need to do some other kind
of transformation on the key.
Yeah. Over here.
man: If my app is not
in App Engine,
but I want to utilize
your framework for queuing,
is the API gonna be available
publicly
so that I could hit it
with requests,
and queue and pull items
from it?
Slatkin: Right,
that's a good question.
So, you know, can I--
So the first answer is
we have no plans,
or nothing to announce
to that right now.
There's nothing stopping you
from implementing this
as an App Engine app itself.
You could--
Especially if you had
some queue operations
to actually, like...
have some introspection
on a queue,
you could do things like that.
You could also use App Engine
to run a queue
and actually send
web hook requests
back to your own
data center
or to some other
virtualized hosting server
or any other provider.
So, you know, you can build
an App Engine app
to basically do whatever you
want with your queue.
It's up to you to kind of
figure out
how you want to do it.
But the fundamental difference
is that it's push, not pull.
So our processing model's very
different from a standard queue,
where you're constantly pulling
off the list.
man: So I would write an app
that I could hit from outside
and give my tasks to,
and then you guys
push it back to me when--
Slatkin: That's totally an
option if you want to do that.
Yeah, you use a URL fetch API
to do that. Yep.
Over here.
man: Yeah, I think you kind of
announced something
called App Engine Labs.
Can you talk about
what that is
and how an
App Engine Lab app works?
Slatkin: Sure.
So App Engine Labs is gonna be
a name space within
our API packages
that lets you import
new modules.
And packages in that name space
will be--
Like I said, they might have
some incompatible changes
that we're gonna make over time.
We're gonna warn you anytime we
do those incompatible changes.
And then eventually,
when it graduates from Labs,
we're gonna move it into
our normal name space,
at which point it will be
backward compatible.
It will not break your code
unless we do
a full version change
where in your app.yaml
you actually have to specify
a new major version.
So...and yeah, we're hoping
to release more APIs
under the Labs moniker.
The idea is that
we don't really know
exactly what we want yet,
and we won't have user feedback.
So this is a way of us
giving you a preview
without locking ourselves
into a problem.
And the other part is what
I said about billing.
We're still trying to figure out
how to bill for this properly.
So that's part of it.
Okay, let me just do another
off of Moderator.
How do you prevent
a malicious user
from using tasks
to create tasks...forkbomb?
How do you avoid punishing
legitimately busy sites?
Yeah, this is
a very good question.
So quotas are one way.
By setting a reasonable,
small, free limit--
You know,
a small or free limit,
we can prevent sites
from doing runaway queuing
and kind of hosing themselves.
We would hope that sites
that are paying customers
who want to do
some useful work
wouldn't try to hose themselves.
But I think this comes into
kind of queue management
and queue introspection tools.
You know, you want to know
if this has happened
if you haven't--
Because you can forkbomb
yourself on accident.
So you want to make sure that
you can diagnose this problem.
Maybe get alerts
when it happens.
Stop a queue, flush a queue.
There's a lot of tooling
we can do around this
to avoid forkbombs
from hurting you.
And how do we avoid punishing
legitimately busy sites?
I think that just fits into
our whole scheme of quotas.
You know, we have
reasonable quotas set
for both free and paying apps.
And as long as you're
within those limits,
it shouldn't make a difference.
Over here.
man: You've spoken before about
warm versus cold apps,
and how the first request is
more expensive and slower
than subsequent requests
in a limited period of time.
How does queuing work
with that?
Slatkin: Yeah, so it's just like
the rest of our infrastructure.
We try to maximize
our cache-hit rate
to your runtimes.
So you know, we'll try to keep
using a hot runtime if we can.
It uses the same
infrastructure serving
to do that.
Let me do a couple more
off the Moderator real quick.
Is there a way to define
the retry policy?
So this is probably, like,
how much to back off,
how quickly to back off.
Again, this is one
of those features
that we want to look into more.
We know that this is a feature
people would like to have.
For now we're gonna have
just a simple
exponential back-off scheme.
I think it starts
at 100 milliseconds.
Something like that.
And we'll go from there.
Will there be a free quota?
Yes, there will be
a free quota.
We'd still like to stick with
the "it's free to get started"
with App Engine.
And we'd like you to start
using this Task Queue API
as soon as we release it.
Will the post request be
limited to one meg?
We're still figuring out
what the maximum size
of tasks should be.
So you know,
it could be anywhere
from 100K to one meg,
10K.
We're not really sure.
We're figuring out
that the best--
We don't want people necessarily
using the Task Queue
for storage.
It should be storing
a description of work to do.
So we are finding
the right balance
in terms of scalability.
And so we'll announce that
when we announce
the rest of the documentation.
And the last one
I'll take here is
is it possible to manually
delete those tombstones?
Right now it's not.
But we want to let you specify
the tombstoning policy
for name tasks
so that you can say, hey,
I want tasks to be
immediately garbage collected,
or I don't.
Or I want them to be
garbage collected in 20 minutes.
We're still figuring out
some more features there.
But we're aware of that
as something that people want.
Over here.
man: Could you give us answer
when the Java support
would come?
Is it, like, weeks,
months, or--
And in the meantime,
what's the best way
to circumvent that using, like,
mix of Python, Java, or...
Slatkin: Yeah,
so I can't give you
a good timeline
on the Java support.
I mean, we'd like it to be
as soon as possible.
So, I mean, within weeks
of our Python launch.
But I'm not really sure.
Yeah, you could use
a hybrid model
of a Python app
with a task queue,
and doing URL fetches
between them.
I wouldn't encourage you
to do that yet.
So hopefully we'll have
code written
so you can actually
take advantage of this in Java
as soon as possible.
That's the best answer
I can give for now.
Over here.
man: How would you go about
counting the number of entities
of a particular kind
in the Datastore?
Is that worth using a queue
to do?
Slatkin: Yeah, so you can do
some aggregations like that.
Essentially you just do
the Schema migration,
except you store the counter
in memcache.
And you just migrate through
all of the entities
doing nothing,
and store the count.
And by the time
you get to the end,
then the memcache contains
the total.
You can do all kinds
of aggregations that way--
sums, averages,
et cetera, et cetera.
So, you know, an aggregation
is just a Schema migration
that does nothing,
I guess, so...yep.
Over here.
man: Yeah, since tasks
are just URL requests,
is there some way that
when the request is run
it can know if it's being run
as a task?
I was thinking about
the mail example.
Slatkin: Yeah, we're gonna have
parts of the queue
that let you have
some introspection
into the request itself.
So you'd say,
"Am I a task?"
And we'll be able to make sure
that Task Queue handlers
aren't run by
non-administrators, et cetera.
So yeah, we're gonna have
all that stuff.
All right,
that's all the time we've got.
Please visit us
in office hours.
We'll answer more
of your questions.
And thanks a lot for coming.
[applause]